what an experience
this film is my word the master is the
new film by Paul Thomas Anderson who
many might refer to as a master director
in his own right it stars Joaquin
Phoenix Philip Seymour Hoffman and Amy
Adams Joaquin Phoenix plays someone who
in one word I could describe as insane
he has an extreme unhealthy even desire
for women think Michael Fassbender and
shame and he's basically just drifting
around from job to job getting kicked
out of places
starting fights eventually stumbles
across this yacht with Philip Seymour
Hoffman on there and Philip Seymour
Hoffman is giving these speeches you
know about this cause that he's involved
with human processing and enlightenment
and whatnot he gets really drawn into
this world to the point where they
create this bond with one another that
leads to all different types of dramatic
problems and some of the best
performances I have seen all year the
master is a film that definitely
requires multiple viewings for you to
latch on to it fully if there are whole
layers behind this film that you are not
going to understand relate to and you're
going to be sitting there scratching
your head on the first viewing it's
going to take more than one viewing for
me to fully grasp this film nevertheless
I still think it is a great movie the
performances in this movie are insanely
good literally they are in sanely good
Joaquin Phoenix is someone else I swear
he's someone else right now he did
something he took something he injected
himself with something he is nuts in
this movie he is nuts
he is insanely nuts he is completely
100% Oscar worthy though this is
probably the best performance I've seen
all year I just he's so good Philip
Seymour Hoffman is just as good and the
scenes they have together where they
face off with each other where they have
dialogue are mind-blowing ly well done
these guys are Oscar caliber firing on
all cylinders just giving amazing
performances of course the film looks
incredibly good I mean the framing in
this movie and the use of focus dear
Lord the use of focus in this movie is
insane I mean the film just looks so so
good
lot of people have said that the movie
is in a way perhaps depicting the
beginning of Scientology and I believe
that to be true because it's pretty
obvious they're not calling it
Scientology it's called the cause
Philip Seymour Hoffman's character is
not called ron Hubbard as the founder of
Scientology is not going to get into the
whole debate of that because that's not
really talking about the quality of this
film on a technical level on a
performance level and on a substance
level is off the chart now I do have a
few small issues with the film and I'll
explain them now some people may not
view this as an issue or a problem I do
though I think it's a little bit of a
flaw sometimes when you can't at least
fully grasp a film on the first viewing
yes certain films like 2001 a Space
Odyssey a lot of these movies like that
you just you feel like I need to watch
that again but that doesn't mean you
didn't understand it the first time
because there are aspects of the way the
master concluded that left me a little
cold and it was simply because I had a
hard time grasping the finality of the
film and exactly what took place it's
one of those movies that you want to go
on I am to be message boards and I love
that about movies but my only flaw with
this movie is that aspect of it where I
wanted to be able to grasp more of the
finale nevertheless this is a must-see
movie if you love movies it's very well
written it looks beautiful the
performances are so good I'm going to
give the master and a - it's not my
favorite paul thomas anderson film that
would probably be there will be blood I
really enjoy it though and it's
definitely worth a watch I'm looking
forward to seeing it again so if you get
a chance to the master if it comes to a
theater near you check it out but be
sure to bring your thinking caps in
because it's definitely the kind of
movie where you are going to want to pay
attention to every frame thanks a lot
for watching guys and as always if you
like this and you can click right here
and get stockman eyes